blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman welcome everybody hope
everybody's weekends are looking good um
last weekend before thanksgiving as a
reminder we're going to be here monday
tuesday wednesday next week and we will
be off thursday and friday for the
thanksgiving holiday few stories i want
to go over with you today you might
remember that the day after maybe it was
two days after
the elections in early november um we
learned that the 17 year old son of the
republican virginia governor-elect glenn
younkin tried to vote two times two
times he tried to vote despite being
over only 17 years old
well finally glenn younkin has been
asked about this and glenn younkin's
reaction
is to be upset
that the media is focused on what his
son did saying
it's really no big deal and
it's sort of unclear if sever 17 year
olds can vote no no it's not um so this
is glenn younkin's reaction he doesn't
like the fact that people care about the
fact that his son tried to vote
illegally
it was just it was silliness i think um
there was there's real confusion
on where a 17 year old can can vote or
not
and so he had had a friend who suggested
that he might be able to vote he went up
and asked
i know my son really was incredibly
respectful young man yeah and uh and he
presented his id and when they said he
couldn't vote he said okay and he went
to school so i i do i am a little bit
frustrated that it's become you know the
media paid so much attention to it it's
my 17 year old son and i really would
like everybody to leave my family alone
yeah um so
let's see if we can break that down
first of all he tried it twice he tried
it twice not once so it's not just well
you know he just said hey would would
you let me vote and no oh well let me
try another place and see if they'll let
me vote
there is no confusion about whether 17
year olds can vote there's if you you
have to be 18 in order to vote now
there's one caveat it's not even a
caveat many people know about which is
if you will be 18 at the time of a
general election
in many i think it's in many states
maybe it's a federal rule
you can vote at 17 in the primary so
imagine i'm 17 year old david pakman at
the time of the primary but at the time
of the general i will be 18 i'd be
allowed to vote in a primary
even if he was confused
they clarified for it they clarified it
for him the first time he tried to vote
so then the second time was what what
are we supposed to believe about the
second time and of course guys
if glenn younkin's son could legally
vote
obviously he would know that and his dad
would be saying all of us are voting for
me obviously
maybe they would have even done it
together for the photo op opportunity
like the idea that it wasn't discussed
in the family or it wouldn't have been
if he was old enough to vote i'm
counting on your vote son are there 17
year olds in this country that don't
know that
i knew from age seven
that you have to be 18 to vote in the
united states if you surveyed 17 year
olds in high schools nationwide what
percentage do you think knows that you
have to be 18 to vote
it's very high number we have an
ignorant country in many ways but just
about every high schooler knows you got
to be 18 to vote
and just imagine for a second what
right-wing media would be doing if it
was terry mcauliffe's 17 year old son
or daughter who had tried twice to vote
in an election that their dad was
running and it's absolutely outrageous
speaking of outrageous
folks this cannot be right this can't
possibly be it is
a trump adviser
lawyer who was involved in the effort to
try to change the election results by
pressuring brad raffensberger in georgia
she has now been appointed to a federal
election panel
it is what it is
trump adviser appointed to panel on u.s
elections writes the associated press
the u.s commission on civil rights
has appointed to a federal election
advisory board a prominent republican
attorney who assisted trump in his
failed effort to overturn the 2020
election results
cleda mitchell is cleta the female
version of cletus i've never heard that
name before cleta mitchell
was named to the board of advisors for
the federal election assistance
commission
the advisory board does not have the
ability to directly make policy but can
recommend voluntary guidelines the eac
certifies voting systems and advises
local election office on offices on
compliance with federal election
regulations
mitchell was nominated by the republican
appointed members on the commission and
approved by a majority vote mitchell is
a prominent republican lawyer who joined
trump on a january second phone call
with georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger on the call trump implored
raffensberger to find him enough votes
for him to be declared the winner
remember that guys i need 11 000 votes
give me a break exactly
um
which was won by biden mitchell claimed
she found possible examples of fraud in
the state but the secretary of state's
office told her her data was incorrect
she says i'm honored to have been
selected with bipartisan support that's
true at least one democrat did vote for
her uh to be given this position
guys it's uh i mean listen
is this
should this be illegal no
is she necessarily going to do something
wrong in this position no i guess not
but the optics of this are absurd she
was on the phone with brad raffensberger
saying we found fraud you got to review
the results and now she's going to be on
a panel that advises
election offices
on voting systems and preventing fraud
it's i don't even know that i can call
it a grift is it just the incestuous
nature of american politics
is it a grift is it is it something else
i don't know
but it's very very depressing
alex jones is now begging for
money from his audience for the lawsuit
that he lost
on the wednesday bonus show i told you
that
in a case where the plaintiffs
are sandy hook parents of victims from
the sandy hook shooting in 2012
the plaintiffs are suing alex jones for
defamation
the court has found against jones but
not on the merits yet
on the basis that jones is obstructing
discovery that's the finding so far so
he's trying to prevent this from even
getting to the next level where he may
actually be found liable for damages for
defamation itself
alex jones is now saying he needs money
he needs two million dollars
in order to pay for all of this take a
look at what he had to say
trials even though i've already been
found guilty by default now they're
going to try to tell the jury how guilty
i am
now even that's deceptive i've been
found guilty by default
you obstructed discovery you're supposed
to allow discovery and you didn't it's
not guilty by default it's you're not
allowing discovery it's going to take a
lot of money to fight this and a lot of
money uh for the appeals and so i can't
spend the money we have paying our crew
and running our independent media outlet
right millions of people right without
your support infowars is doing its most
important work ever right now so i would
argue that that's not true
this is a no-brainer please go to
make a ten dollar donation a thousand
dollar donation wealthy people out there
your free speech is being destroyed
infowars is just the first you know uh
most wealthy people
most people but certainly most wealthy
people know their free speech is not
being destroyed their free speech is
fine i'm going to fall and if wealthy
folks don't start spending their money
promoting liberty promoting freedom
we're going to lose this country and
we're going to lose the world tyranny so
please go to
saveinfowars.com it's give sin go
they're great folks they're patriots
we're banned everywhere else even be
able to raise money and this will help
keep us the fight for the next few years
so i've never issued an alert this
serious i need your help right now
that's also not true there's always some
alert stand up for yourself stand up for
your right stand up for free speech
stand up for america and don't let these
bullies intimidate anybody please donate
right now and save him okay
now that is what desperation looks like
but i hate to tell you guys
he's raising a bunch of money this uh
campaign started a day and a half ago
the goal is two million dollars he's
already raised just a few dollars short
of a hundred thousand dollars by the
time that this uh clip gets published
and today's podcast gets published
it may be a lot more money so this is
what desperation looks and sounds like
um i guess the risk is we may lose
infowars altogether if we don't donate
to alex jones which doesn't seem like it
would really be that bad of a thing
quite frankly it seems like actually
that that might be uh something that has
positive influence so alex jones as i
told you not yet actually found liable
uh on the merits of the defamation case
but they are declining to actually do
what they're supposed to do when it
comes to discovery to even allow
this to go forward uh despite a judge's
request slash demands depending on what
you want to call them
um and now alex jones is turning it into
the grift of grifts uh he made money by
making uh by lying about sandy hook he
then got sued and now he's trying to
make money by painting himself as the
victim as a result of not participating
in what the court said he has to do
discovery for this case uh i don't think
anybody in my audience is going to
donate but people are donating he's
already up to almost a hundred thousand
dollars and probably more by the time we
publish this clip it's an amazing time
that we live in
um i want to remind everybody again we
will be off next week thursday and
friday for the thanksgiving holiday just
so people don't email me say david
where's the show where's the show we're
going to be off thursday and friday we
will be here monday tuesday wednesday
we're going to take a quick break i want
to hear from some of you i have
questions to answer i have emails to
address and show you you can also of
course find me on twitter
deepakman look forward to hearing from
you
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
please make sure that you are signed up
at joinpackman.com grab a david pakman
show membership our program primarily
depends on people signing up for those
memberships and we do an extra show
every day called the bonus show for our
members we also have commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
sign up at joinpackman.com great way to
support independent media
let's talk to people in the audience
people in the audience we do this via
discord davidpakman.com
discord
um and let's see who's uh who who wants
to chat today let's start today
with aaron from los angeles california
aaron you were on the air
david uh i just wanted to ask you uh
real quick because i know that you've
spoken this on this a bit but um what's
your opinion on
let's say a revolving door or like an
open door uh
border policy because uh um i've been
reading a lot and i like actually
although
i'm not a really big fan of reagan one
of the few things i did enjoy i did like
about his
um about his policies were his
immigration policies such as like the
bronzerto program
and different programs such as like
granting amnesty to the undocumented
immigrants i was just wondering what's
your take on uh immigration well when
you say revolving door or open door
would you you mean just anybody can come
in and out work
no screening whatsoever what what do you
mean specifically yeah um well like or
you know
at least alleviating it for seasonal
workers to be able to come in during the
um
um
agricultural seasons when it's busy and
then allowing them to return at any time
usually during the off-season to go back
home yeah i i a lot of those things i'm
very much in favor of i do think there
need to be some immigration controls i
am not for an open border i am i am not
for
uh this sort of fully libertarian
libertarian idea of total free movement
of labor and people i i just practically
speaking i don't think that that would
work but we've got to give permanent
status to daca recipients number one
guest worker program absolutely um
people often when they say shut this
down shut that down they don't
understand not only the degree to which
industries are dependent on
workers from other countries sometimes
undocumented but also
why some of the things that they have
are far cheaper as a result of that
labor and it's very hypocritical when
you hear people who want the cheap stuff
if stuff gets more expensive they would
attack whoever the president is but they
also want that very same president to
quote keep people out incoherent doesn't
make sense and i'm for a whole bunch of
the things you're proposing not open
borders but for a lot of the things
you're talking about yes
okay uh in terms of border security
though how would that work because from
my understanding our current state of
border security is not only notoriously
corrupt but it's also just like not
working i mean uh people are still able
to like
it's mostly there to be able to prevent
um i guess like drug traffickers from
coming in but they're still managing to
like come in at a rate that benefits
their type of business in industry so i
was just wondering like in terms of
border security how should we reframe
that so it's not just like a black hole
that we're just spending a lot of the
taxpayer money on well two things we are
disproportionately focused on people
just physically crossing the border
rather than people flying in and just
staying here or coming in with a visa
and staying so one of the first things
you have to think about is
you can
disincentivize people from doing the
illegal crossings by making it less
necessary to do that and so a lot of the
programs you're talking about guest
worker programs etc
they they remove a lot of the need to
come in the way that you're talking
about so we just need to be thinking
about it you're completely right that if
you just change one thing it doesn't
change the entire dynamic we need to be
thinking much bigger
thank you david appreciate the call
thank you so much there's aaron from los
angeles
let's go next to uh why don't we try
mitch from toronto canada mitch you are
on the air
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine yeah
okay great um long time listener i
actually just uh became a member the
other day great uh love your program
thank you i appreciate that
for sure um so i don't know if you
follow anything going on in canada but
what i wanted to ask you about was more
i guess cross-border anyway and it has
to do with the environment and kind of
like where things are going in the
future in terms gas prices are getting
crazy up here uh in canada at least in
ontario they're getting crazy and i
think they're getting pretty expensive
in in the us as well
um
what are your thoughts on like moving
people to electric cars subsidizing that
um and if you have any thoughts on like
how that how that's playing in with with
home ownership condo or otherwise i
would love to hear your thoughts on that
kind of scenario let me i'll get back to
the second part yes i mean listen gas
prices are going up they are not at
historic highs but they are higher
um i am a huge advocate of electric cars
i've had one now for over a year i think
that there's an incredible double
standard where you have the very same
people complaining about high gas prices
and blaming them on biden want to
prevent biden from doing more on
building an electric vehicle charging
network and subsidizing electric
vehicles incentivizing electric vehicles
etc etc we have some subsidies at the
state and some at the federal level for
electric cars it's not nearly enough so
if you want to
solve the gas price problem let's get
off of gas
that's number one
number two
in terms of the home ownership and condo
thing
i listened to a very interesting podcast
recently which basically says the path
forward is we need government to
subsidize retrofitting you go building
by building structure by structure
and you put solar panels on the roof or
in the yard depending on whether it's
urban rural
you replace and retrofit heating systems
to be modern ultra efficient often they
are heat pump mini split systems
although there are many other ways that
there's not just one system but you know
we got to get off of burning oil for
heating
certainly baseboard electric is like one
of the least efficient it's a disaster
you replace stoves with ultra efficient
new electric and i love gas as much as
the next person but in this way
you create each building
takes in solar power has the most
efficient electric
elements for cooking and heating and
you've got a car charger so you're
charging the car with the sun
this is the process you've just got to
start doing it you've got to you've got
to start going building by building
government's got to figure out how to do
it we got to get off this gasoline stuff
we just have to yeah
yeah yeah yeah what is that podcast i'm
curious where you're getting some of
your information i wish i remembered
what it was i i just don't um no problem
no let me see if you let me give me give
me one second let me see if it's still
in my spotify history i'm just looking
at it on my underwear well you're
looking i'm also curious what kind of
electric car you've been driving i've
been driving a tesla
okay you've been driving to tesla now
are you driving the uh like the van
sedan i think that's the model x or are
you on the the model s
well i don't want to say specifically
because the vehicle is kind of
conspicuous you know yeah um
i don't um
you know i it might have been it might
have been brain stuff but i don't know
i don't know what the podcast was but in
any case is it in the winter how do you
find it in the winter well the thing
with electric vehicles is when you use
the battery
to run the heat pump to heat the car
it does consume significantly more
battery so the range is notably
decreased in the winter it's never been
a problem particularly with the
supercharging network and a high-speed
charger at home it's never caused a
problem for me
but there's trips where in the summer i
might finish the trip at 40 percent
where i'm rolling in at 22 in winter if
i'm running the heat at 70 or something
like that
that's good to know hey thanks so much
for taking my call i really appreciate
it and um i would love to hear
uh
more of your thoughts on this kind of
stuff on your program at any point if
you decide to cover it um i'm really
interested in in some of the more
granular stuff around this and would
love to hear more of your thoughts all
right i very much appreciate the call
thanks so much david all right take care
uh guys pretty solid calls today so far
let's not ruin it please please nobody
ruin it um why don't we go
next
to brett from i believe it's indiana is
that right brett
correct can you hear me i can hear you
fine
all right perfect hold on a second i
gotta go somewhere discreet sorry uh-oh
discretion is key with many of these
calls
right i'm at school so i don't want to
offend anybody but anyway so two
questions and i'll be quick so please so
so for me as a national guard member do
you think
it would be cheaper
if the usa spent more on the national
guard as compared to active duty i don't
know just i don't know if you're
informed on that or not i just was
curious as to your thoughts on that i
don't know enough about that to comment
substantively to be honest
or i understand i mean it's just
if we spent more domestically it
certainly
mathematically could save more because
you know we wouldn't have to spend money
sending them to another country and we
would could focus on domestic issues you
know because there are like military
jobs where like they do something as
simple as work on railroad trucks or you
know
you know washers and dryers you know
there's even combat medics but
that's just my view it's an interesting
question i will look into it
i appreciate it so
do you know so here's my last question
do you know if there's
with the infrastructure bill that biden
just signed yep
um
there's a possibility of magnetic trains
being included into it or because i
tried to look into that and i didn't see
anything about it so i know that there's
a there's a designation of money
specifically for rail and there's also a
designation for
um uh public transit and both of those
things can touch train travel i don't
know let me put it this way i haven't
seen anything about maglev trains
specifically but that doesn't mean it is
in there or it isn't in there i just
haven't seen it at that level of
granularity
right because when i was in paris i went
from paris to madrid on a magnetic train
i was very impressed by the speed i was
like wow holy crap i i like you did you
say madrid
yeah madrid does paris
are you talking about madrid spain
yeah i like that i've never heard it
pronounced madrid but i sort of like it
well it depends on what language i'm
speaking so if i'm speaking spanish i'll
say like madrid but if i'm speaking it
to like you know an english speaker i'll
say it as madrid hey listen if it's work
no i love it if it's working for you
keep going i like it
all righty i appreciate your time all
right thanks brett there's brett from
indianapolis dropping in a variety of
different opinions questions comments
etc you know la i believe last week we
tried to talk to isaiah from
arkadelphia and we had a technical
problem let's try isaiah
we didn't get on last week did we isaiah
hi david can you can you understand me
now i can
so there's no
loud background noise of some variety
i'm hearing no power tools i'm hearing
no deli slicers or weights being dropped
it's very clear today
you know i don't own a deli slicer and i
think it'd be cool if i did i think i'd
be moving up in the world without that
um i was just um serious i've noticed
that a lot on the left
because of um
a lot of
a lot of people on the left don't like
to acknowledge that china and russia are
really
threats
um and i'm not gonna like call out
specific names for such
but when looking at
i'm sure um you're familiar with what's
going on with belarus but for your
audience um the nation of belarus which
is basically a puppet of russia
is essentially engaging in human um
human trafficking
and espionage to basically sabotage the
border of the european union
and i feel like
if you ever bring up that hey
these countries
may not necessarily align with u.s
foreign policy that we may disagree with
at times that does not mean they are
good countries they are
threatening to
the liberal democratic world order
yeah i feel like there's just something
that needs to be acknowledged more often
yeah i you know um you're you're very
much you're
it's a very astute point which is
there's a contingent of the left that i
basically
make every effort not to engage with i
just don't i don't find them interesting
these are
lefties who in in the 1960s and 70s in
argentina when my parents were growing
up
um they were all over the place and it
was sort of like the
the west is bad people
and it doesn't matter if anyone if if
you if you're a part of the west and you
say anyone else is doing something
that's bad you're an imperialist you're
whatever
it's a really old script and when i see
these folks now
it just reminds me of the people that my
parents described kind of my parents
very much on the left in argentina in
the 60s and 70s but they found those
supposed leftists really as interfering
with social democratic goals not not
actually helping i try not to engage
with them because it's just so boring
it's so it's so passe
but you're absolutely right there are
people like for example if you look at
the comments of my recent clip where i
said hey you know what
um a lot of the china virus xenophobia
that we're seeing against asian
americans it's disgusting there's no
place for it but here's some actual
stuff that we could look at that china's
doing that we should be concerned about
it doesn't align with my values and a
lot of the comments are but david the us
does bad stuff too or you didn't mention
this one thing that the uh
we're not talking about that we're not
talking we're just i'm pointing we're
having a conversation where i'm pointing
out hey here's things that don't align
with my values i'm not saying go to war
i'm not saying anything else and you're
absolutely yeah and it's it's especially
disappointing to me because i'm fairly
young i was born after 9 11. okay and
what got me
engaged with politics is every single
day
growing up being reminded hey we're at
war in afghanistan iraq
and should not be i know people who
serve were just a few years older me
served in iraq also know people whose
parents served in iraq yeah in iraq and
afghanistan so that was never a present
thing so
when i voted for for biden and i live in
arkansas so my vote doesn't really
matter but i still voted for him
just him getting out of afghanistan even
with all the issues afterwards was
enough for me and then when i saw the
west
anytime anyone would say
okay but the taliban is still bad and
china moving in and their influence is
also bad
it's like
two things can be true at once the basis
of being against a war in afghanistan or
something like that is right
you don't want destabilizing
and
war words sure yeah there's a lot of
people where it's like it sounds like
they they say
okay either china is doing something
that's bad
or the u.s is bad and it's like hey hold
on a second the u.s has a history of
doing bad things and here's stuff some
stuff china's doing that
it's it's the black and white thinking
is uh is is disturbing and i'm glad
you're thinking and talking about this
stuff that's also curious um did you did
you vote in the recent argentine
elections i did not no i i moved to the
us when i was five so i've never been
registered to vote in argentina and my
um my documents aren't even current so
if i wanted to vote in argentina
first i would have to renew my documents
to be up to date uh update where i'm
living register as someone who's living
in another state and wants to vote it
you know i just have i've not i've not
done it i've never voted in argentina
yeah i saw the uh
perroness uh party suffered a setback
but i to be completely honest just don't
know enough about argentine politics to
know if any of the newer parties are
actually
that much different in any way well you
just from the last 30 seconds you know
more than 99.9 of americans so consider
that a consider that a success
i i just know that south american
politics like to be pul like to be
populous and say power to the people and
then it's one family controls the party
and pockets all the money yes yes that's
very often the way it goes no you're
you're
but hold on a second you're not
criticizing america when you say that
i mean i'm just a
oh no i was meaning specifically i know
i'm kidding around there are people the
same people you were talking about
earlier they would hear you say that and
they would go but the u.s has families
too i think they would say like well we
have the bushes no like the bush family
three i will say arkansas is getting
kind of a dynastic thing i don't know if
you've kept up with this sarah huckabee
yeah yeah yeah yeah who
is the only candidate now she's going to
be governor all the others dropped out
and endorsed her it's crazy so it's
crazy and her father was
i think for like 13 years here yeah mike
huckabee was a long time governor all
right my friend listen we've you've said
it all i'm gonna let you go okay
okay thank you very good guys let's take
a quick break i'm still taking calls
we're gonna take a quick break and then
go right back to the phones in a moment
stay with me
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
let's take a few more calls via the
david pakman show discord you can find
it at davidpakman.com
discord slash discord is the place let's
go to harper from europe europe is such
a vague location harper
oh yeah i'm actually in france right now
sorry all right love france yeah
yeah um i've been here for about a month
anyway uh regarding the kyle written
australia no i'm kidding um
i just want to say since i've been here
for over a month and you were in spain
in august i wanted to touch on the whole
anti-vaccine sure anti-vaxx
scene yes um
yeah um so i've heard very often about
american politics that were sort of like
kind of a crap show and
people look from other countries in on
the united states and like what the heck
is going on but i wanted to say there's
sort of an exception to be made and not
sure if you if you agree
with the anti-vac situation
uh here while i'm in france it seems
like since i left the united states i'm
from california
uh things are just as bad over here
and yes it's one of the factors we've
talked about it in france i don't want
to cut you off but just so my to remind
my audience
i have mentioned in france they are
having a serious anti-vaxx issue italy
as well by the way but in france i think
the government did something astute
which is instead of doing a straight
correct me if i'm wrong instead of doing
a straight up vax requirement they've
just said if you want to go here here
there there there you need proof of
vaccination you don't have to go and get
a vaccine but if you want to hang out in
these cafes or movie theaters or
whatever the case may be and it is it
has made as i understand it a lot more
people sort of say well i really want to
do that so i'm going to go and get a
vaccine
yeah that that's that's absolutely true
um and then there's a a small aspect of
this that i don't quite see in the
united states that i would argue makes
it slightly worse over here okay and
that is that um
the if you split the the groups people
who are vaccinating people who are not
there's more animosity over here between
those two groups than there is in the
united states really it seems a bit more
tame where i came from yeah yeah uh and
then i was in catalonia and it seemed
about the same over there and i was
wondering since you were in spain which
uh has part of catalonia about half or
maybe two thirds
was spain
like in in sort of the realm of of of
countries that have an anti-vaxx uh
situation or was it like not at all no
in fact
at the time that i was in spain spain
was only about 45 vaccinated but when
european countries were polled do you
want the vaccine
spain was off the charts it was
something like 88 or 91 percent of
spaniards were saying i plan to get
vaccinated which was one of the highest
in all of europe
ah interesting yeah arthen thank you all
right thank you appreciate that great uh
great call from france there france
let's go next
why don't we try
chris from colorado chris you're on the
air
chris from colorado don't be our first
dropped call we want you to unmute so
that i can hear you
oh no chris from colorado last chance my
friend
and that is too bad i thought maybe we
would get through the entire day without
a drop but
we didn't do it we didn't do it let's go
to mike from massachusetts you're on the
air
oh hey david can you hear me yes i can
long time listener first time caller
also obviously from my title from
massachusetts happy to have someone from
my home state doing what you do pleasure
pleasure
um i guess my question is a little bit
it's a couple years out before this is a
real concern but
um for the 2024
election obviously a lot can happen
between now and then
but as things stand right now there is a
real possibility that if trump
were to run he could win yes correct
absolutely so there's i believe there's
an argument to be made that trump's
attempt to overturn the election in 2020
really came down to a handful or maybe a
half a dozen or so people that
blocked him at key steps that would have
given him huge uh opportunities to
actually achieve what he was trying to
do
given like the increase of like
self-described mega candidates that
we've seen running for various state
positions and theoret and whatnot and
you know with trump having the
popularity that he has and most likely
going to keep that popularity over the
next three years or so
if trump were to run and theoretically
lose
do you see a possibility where he could
actually pull off what he tried in 2020
or theoretically if he ran and won
could he then install enough people into
key positions that he could actually
completely change the system when even
after he's gone
republicans could run the whole run the
show regardless of what the votes are
you know the latter one seems
far-fetched i don't know that
80-plus-year-old trump
as president in an even more kind of
dazed and confused state than he was in
during his first four years
is really going to do that i i think
that that's kind of far-fetched my i
think the first concern you mentioned is
a more legitimate one which is
it's looking good for republicans in the
house in 2022 on redistricting alone
never mind actually flipping seats
it's looking okay for republicans in
either 22 or 24 taking control back of
the senate i don't know that biden gets
re-elected i don't know that if he bails
and kamala is the nominee that she wins
so by by january of 2025 you could again
have total republican control of the
white house house and senate and that's
really really scary and uh even if they
only have control of some of those
could they
somehow
use whatever resources they have to give
a win to trump even if he didn't earn it
in the way they fell short of in 2020. i
don't want to be hyperbolic but i also
don't want to write it off i think there
are real concerns
about if trump loyalists control more
governorships the house and senate in 24
and if trump narrowly loses in 2024
that there is a lot that motivated
trumpist elected officials could try in
order to put trump in the white house
even though he didn't win do i think
they would succeed i still think they
probably wouldn't but the fact that
we're even talking about it in these
terms is very scary
that's fair um
to my somebody to my latter point i
guess i'd ask it's not so much to
trump's benefit but if he were to win in
2024 yeah and let's say like you said
republicans control the house control
the senate
could they now that they've seen how
close they can get to actually
overturning an election could they spend
that term the 2024 to 2028 setting
things up so they can essentially run
the show going down the road even when
trump goes away they could try yes i
think i think you're that's a much more
plausible way which is it's not about
trump per se it's really about others
laying further groundwork and that was
more of my question it's not even a
conspiracy theory in the sense that
they've been doing it with voter id for
15 years they've been this is what they
do they do it with redistricting so of
course they would continue to try and
find new ways
okay that was more my question the first
time around i guess i didn't articulate
that quite right but no problem i
appreciate that my pleasure i appreciate
the call
all right have a good one i'm sure i'll
be calling back again soon all right
there's mike from massachusetts let's go
next to jamie from canada jamie from
canada you're on the air
hey david how's it going it's going well
thank you
um i was just wondering how do you
think the that biden's agenda is going
because we've had basically the endless
frontier act which passed the senate
surprisingly did not pass that hasn't
passed the house yet then he has the
american rescue plan which which he
signed into law and then he just signed
the bipartisan infrastructure into law
but that so that's like he's hitting
three so far but
technically but he also has the the john
lewis voting rights act and then the for
the people after the the right to vote
act or whatever they're calling it now i
was just wondering um so he has about
maybe six or seven pieces of legislation
on his agenda what realistically uh what
do you think we're going to see
being passed
oh it's such a tough question because
you
candidates make way more promises than
they can ever
keep or make a reality
um
at the same time you also had biden
dealing with covid and the delta wave
and i've expressed disappointment that
more hadn't been done
um
my expectation is that maybe not by the
end of this year but by the end of the
first quarter of next year there will be
some additional major accomplishment by
joe biden i don't know if it'll be the
build back better spending bill or if it
will be something else including items
you mentioned
but i think that the way i would say it
is biden's doing okay on getting some
things done
although it's starting to feel a little
bit light we had the covet stimulus
um vaccination rollout now we have a
much smaller infrastructure bill than
initially proposed signed i think in
order to get back to like a b
he needs one more big piece of
legislation by the end of march of next
year that's kind of my mindset right now
and he said i i think he said this but
he said i'm going to use every trick in
my book to try to get this voting rights
um passed he and he said i'm putting
camilla in charge and um
i was just wondering what you thought of
that
yeah i um
am unsure
as to whether the vice president
um can get it done i mean i there's no
way to sugarcoat it i i hope that she
can
i'm unsure and so far
she
does not have major accomplishments
under her belt but that's you know it's
just i'm not saying it as a criticism
it's just she just doesn't right now and
she's not particularly popular right now
i hope that she can do it i don't know
if she can
that's fine um
one last thing before i go is that my
realistic expectations
my my over performing hope expectations
for the senate in 2022 is 54 56
democrats but i know realistically we
might get only 52 or or maybe just hold
the 50.
let's just hope republicans don't take
over i'm setting my sights much lower
than you
yeah yeah um
because people are telling me you gotta
lower your expectations you gotta think
it's just gonna be 50 or 51 dems i think
i think cautious optimism is the way to
go i appreciate the call and yes thank
you hope you have a nice day and canada
is really nice it is a little bit chilly
i love canada we love canada here thank
you jamie from canada very much
appreciate the call
um why don't we
check in here
with brian from phoenix brian you're on
the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
i was listening to one of your recent
episodes regarding uh the kyle
rittenhouse shooting you were talking
about uh how it's representative of all
of the uh the problems with gun culture
and um you know the
uh the fact that kyron house felt
justified in going there at all is sort
of indicative of all of those issues
yes parenting gun culture vigilantism
etc
would you um you know
i actually i agree with a lot of that
would you also say that there's a
similar issue with the way that um
many of the protesters felt justified in
being there around like the uh
particulars around the jacob lake
shooting um in terms of
you know is there any onus on the media
that portrayed the shooting in the way
that it did given um you know what we
know about it now that you know the
what was occurring before the police got
there the kids in the car the knife and
the seat all of those things those are
there's kind of two questions there and
i think it's important to be really
careful the protesters to the extent
that people were protesting i'm not
talking about looting arson or anything
like that that stuff's against the law
and i'm against it but
the protesting and marching and holding
signs and saying things
um
constitutionally protected
paramount uh element of the united
states of america right that that's
that is beyond reproach as long as
you're doing it in a non-violent way
the second part is
were they
ginned up into a frothy state
because of media coverage which could
have been different
that is totally plausible i don't
remember
the coverage now and i
you know i would need to study it more
it's completely plausible that media
could bear a responsibility
for raising tensions i'm not saying they
did i'm just saying it's theoretically
possible but that's a different issue
from the pro i don't think we could say
that there's a problem with a culture
where people feel like it's okay to go
and protest that it is okay to go and
protest and we want to be really clear
about that
definitely yeah thanks for tuning in all
right brian thank you so much for the
call that's going to do it for calls
today i do plan and hope to take more
calls again soon and i will speak to you
then
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
alright let's get into this week's
mailbag email bag as many of you know
the email bag ranges from the extremely
low brow ignorant and hateful to really
interesting ideas suggestions
questions all sorts of different things
info davidpakman.com is the place to
send your emails remember we get 500
emails a day and we go over about eight
a week so i just want everybody to you
know i get emails and then i get emails
about why haven't you read my email yet
uh and sometimes i get the second one
within hours of the first one it's like
hey guys i do sleep sometimes you know
okay let's get to the emails first one
it's from a guy who's been writing in
for a while his name is gary b
and he said did you get your booster yet
dumbass and in fact i did i i mentioned
last week that i was going this is an
anti-vaxx nut who's been emailing for a
long time
i think he writes in sometimes about
motor oil in vaccines if i recall
correctly i got my booster on um
thursday
i got it at 4 30
went to bed around 11 had a little bit
of arm pain
and then the next morning woke up at 7
30. a little bit feverish although i
didn't have a fever headache headache
like behind the eyes
and just achy took a tylenol with
breakfast and that helped a lot worked a
regular day slept a lot friday night and
then was basically better on saturday so
i am now uh triple vaxxed and i'm
feeling boosted and all of these
different things but yes gary thank you
for asking i did indeed
get my booster some call it a third dose
they're probably coming for everybody is
what it seems to be given again we've
got another rise in cases
and especially what we know about the
decreased efficacy particularly of the
jnj vaccine but in general
i by the way i got two moderna
shots as my initial regimen
and then i got a modern booster as well
okay second email from jake jake says
john bolton predicted trump won't run
for president again in 2024 because he
fears being known as a loser if it
doesn't work out this is what michael
cohen keeps saying trump will not run
because he can't handle the potential
humiliation these guys close to trump
seem to be sure of this jonathan yeah
i've spoken to michael cohen about this
directly and i think that he's
completely
he's making a completely plausible case
i think the question is we don't yet
know whether trump is likely to lose in
2024. as i've said before if republicans
do well in 22 and biden doesn't do well
in his uh third year of his presidency
second and third and into the election
cycle
and in particular if biden doesn't even
run for re-election
i think that it looks okay for trump i
think a trump versus biden rematch is
good for trump
i think if biden doesn't run and kamala
harris is the democratic nominee i think
that's good for trump so i agree with
what michael cohen says and said to me
when i was on his show i agree i haven't
seen this john bolton thing but i i'm
sure it's
it might be right um
i think if trump knows he will lose he
won't do it because he doesn't want to
suffer a humiliation
i just don't know that it's clear trump
will lose yet and so we're going to be
watching that it's a question we all
care about here's a longer voicemail but
it's a very very interesting one this
one is from mark
and mark wanted to weigh in on why
people on the right call me gay
mark says david you asked why people on
the right assume you're gay i am a gay
man who is politically active and i have
some ideas based in personal experience
with right-wingers first most of us who
are actually gay realize you're straight
and you're an ally
i'm very glad for all the straight
allies we have i've never picked up on a
gay vibe from you my gaydar does not
even register as much as a blip when i
watch your youtube videos listen to mark
however
for a lot of people on the right
particularly the far right there is just
nothing worse than being gay hence gay
becomes the perfect epithet
if they don't like your politics then
that means you're gay if they don't like
your position on social issues then that
means you're gay if they don't like you
period that must be because you're gay
and they're straight
no self-respecting right winger would
tolerate a gay person in their midst
except possibly those who suddenly
decided they were quote cured and we all
know how long gay cures
last
very interesting email from mark
um
so there it is it's sort of like a
presented without comment
very interesting to hear from mark on
that next email is from jessica
jessica says hi mr pacman i've walked
watched your show for a while now and
i've heard you say you're a progressive
but not a democrat would you say you're
independent then just wondering since if
someone said they were progressive i'd
think they meant a progressive
democratic
love your videos thanks so jessica with
total peace and love you may have a few
terms confused progressive is a
political ideology
sort of like socialist someone says
they're a socialist they might be
a member of the democratic party or not
uh they might be a member of the
socialist party to the extent that
sometimes it exists and sometimes does
not but socialist can be an ideology
uh maybe that's a bad example since
there is a socialist party listen
progressive can be
a member of the democratic party or not
um i've never been a member of the
democratic party i am an independent but
i tend to vote for democrats when that
makes sense in uh partisan elections
all right i hope i've cleared it up
geez
john says hey david love your channel
what do you think of the dem what do you
think the democrats are going to do in
2024
joe biden will be just shy of 82 at the
time of the election i suspect that will
be a major issue for many voters do you
think he will be renominated or step
aside and support kamala harris i like
kamala but i think she's about as
charismatic as al gore have the
democrats painted themselves into a loss
in 2024 john from indiana listen john
it's so early that we don't have
definitive answers to these questions
that being said
i have already stated i have serious
concerns i think 80 plus year old joe
biden
after being hammered on by republicans
rightly or wrongly for four years
against trump
i don't think it looks good for joe
biden if joe biden steps aside and the
nomination is
given to kamala harris or if she wins it
in a contest
and then it's trump versus kamala
i don't think it's very good desantis
versus kamala i don't think it's very
good for uh democrats so i am very
worried about that exact scenario
and uh painted themselves into a loss is
starting to editorialize in a way that i
don't i don't know that i'm ready to do
yet
but let's just say
my policy tends to be
i talk about the next election which
right now is 2022.
my concerns are so high for 2024 that i
have found myself wandering into talking
about it more than i typically would and
john from indiana brings up
exactly some of the concerns that i have
next the oh we've got some bonus ones
these are from facebook
these are these are tough okay these are
tough someone wrote to me
and said you need to do more research
doctors and scientists are speaking out
against this vaccine that was all one
sentence
going on to say you're just following
the lies like a good little sheep a ton
you know there's this idea there's this
general understanding
that facebook is particularly a cesspool
of anti-vaxx non-thinking
uh sometimes undereducated
rants and raves that are barely
intelligible
anecdotally we're experiencing that
we're experiencing that and i would say
close to half of the messages we get on
our facebook page result in the person
just being banned because they're either
hurling insults or otherwise harassing
people okay another a facebook special
for you today
i'm going to read this as written
where do you get your information from
bud we still have our constitutional
right of freedom of choice
i don't know what in particular this
refers to
my instinct is
that it's somehow
vaccination related as well
next one
you were a total and complete piece of s
pushing lies and conflicting truth
research nuremberg journalists held
accountable
and then f yourself
with a heated curling iron
you effing worthless sack of s you will
notice
period exclamation point which is an
interesting grammatical curiosity
as well as random capitalization of
words like complete
journalists
the f word yourself sac is capitalized
reminiscent of donald trump it's
actually very interesting how a lot of
trumpian lunatics
have picked up on this random
capitalization of nouns and other words
in the middle of sentences so there's
that and then lastly coming perfectly
timed on the heels of what some call a
booster and some call a third dose
you are so lost you must have a five you
must have five g
vacs sickened because you can't be that
stupid and here we have
one two three four different places
where there's just extra spaces between
words
random capitalization
sentence fragments run on sentence
missing apostrophe and can't
um it it would actually be
so if i said to you i have a sentence
this long
and it has close to double digits of
spelling and grammatical errors you
would say sir that can't be
but it is
but it is it is hard to believe
um we are going to be off next week
thursday and friday we will have a
truncated schedule because of the
um thanksgiving holiday here in the
united states of course many in our
audience don't celebrate thanksgiving
they're not in the united states we will
have a monday tuesday wednesday show and
we will be off thursday friday just
don't want people to be worried or think
the show got pulled off the air
that's next week we still have a
fantastic bonus show for you today you
can sign up at joinpakman.com and get
access to the bonus show it's an extra
program every day
just for you
who say i am going to support this
program financially you can use the
coupon code better21 to get a discount i
look forward to seeing you there or we
will be back monday with brand new
programming just for you
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com
david pakman